it is a picture of dedication
70 years since her father died and seven
decades since she became queen
in a rare moment marking the start of
the platinum jubilee year a camera was
allowed in to film her at work last week
sir edward young her private secretary
talking her through her red box this is
the outline program including a message
from america to mark an appropriate
women of leadership award very nice to
see
some extremely extremely nice comments
including one from president biden
oh that's very kind isn't it
it is a clear display this is a monarch
still as committed as ever albeit with
an eye on the future
in the message the queen is saying
principally that she rededicates herself
to serve the nations of which she's head
of state and as head of the commonwealth
but she's also
underlining how important it is for her
that when her son becomes king
his wife is seen as queen consort
exactly in the same way as her mother
and her grandmother queen elizabeth and
queen mary were for king george vi
and king george v
thanking his mother prince charles wrote
we are deeply conscious of the honor
represented by my mother's wish as we
have sought together to serve and
support her majesty and the people of
our communities my darling wife has been
my own steadfast support throughout
a king who had indeed spent his strength
in the selfless service of his people on
this day at sandringham in 1952 king
george vi died making his daughter queen
at just 25.
a young monarch and then a long life
allowing the country to celebrate a
silver golden diamond and now platinum
jubilee
[Music]
crowds disappointed not to see her today
but wanting to mark the moment what does
she mean to you it is a remarkable
milestone that no other monarch has ever
achieved
yeah i suppose that's the thing isn't it
that she has been on the throne for 70
years and so it's quite an achievement
you think
that's been all our lives hasn't it yes
yes and a bit more
it's a unique occasion one that we
should never witness again i wouldn't
think
so it's nice to be at sandringham
close to her master yeah it has been a
difficult couple of years for the royal
family and as her relatives gather
around her for the platinum jubilee year
the queen herself will no doubt remind
us that these milestone moments aren't
just about her but also for showcasing
and protecting the institution and this
weekend she has delivered a message loud
and clear about what she thinks is best
for the future i see them all they've
all signed it for all her modesty the
queen knows that her words matter the
first british monarch to ever reach a
platinum jubilee her experience and the
respect she commands cannot be matched